hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to bendy and the ink
machine and welcome back to the final
chapter of this twisted story of a
Disney gone wrong now I don't know how
this is gonna end but in the last
chapter we actually started getting into
some really interesting things about the
universe about how everything is made of
ink everything and what happens when a
society starts to rely on ink entirely
and what does that do and how does it
blur the reality between life and arts
and all of that metaphysical [ __ ]
going on there oh is that so you guys
sing me to sleep here I know you're just
lulling me into a false sense of
security
hello everyone knows that song who are
you why are you hearing I was invited by
an old friend and now I can't leave then
you know more than we do one minute we
don't even exist just thoughts and the
next minute this place are you gonna let
me out of here down here strangers
aren't good things how can we trust you
we don't even know what you are my name
is Henry I used to work here I
I honestly don't know my name so they
call me Alice but I'm no angel you go
back and rest we'll talk again later hmm
so this is the this is the actual
cartoon come to life and that means that
the last thing that we saw Henry um
Henry this is the first time this is the
first time that we've had a voice ever I
mean amber we didn't have a voice before
but something absolutely wrong about
that ha Bors hey buddy how you doing
whoa okay that's a little threatened ha
ha ha bars
what are you doing Boris we you and I
you and I we got along unless I was just
some other version of you that didn't
really make any sense
you must be got ink for me oh good hi oh
that's ok I've been scarfing down ink
since the day I got you ok hi Boris hey
ok that's little rude ok well you know
I'd like the other Boris the one with
X's 4 eyes so it was probably a horrible
mangled doll that was harvested for ink
organs look man Boris what happened to
us I know you're watching me yeah what
else am i watching it's just a little
creepy ok the one there rights on the
walls we all do for some poor souls down
here it's the only way they can be heard
uh-huh
but don't want to touch the ink for too
long it can claim you pull you back I
was messing with things I shouldn't have
been and he he was there why do you call
him tom he just seems to respond to it
well I don't think he's very fond of me
let me show you something huh a while
back I was mapping out one of the upper
levels when I noticed something
reflecting off a piece of glass I held
up the glass looked through and on the
wall behind me was a hidden message
right there in plain sight so I kept
looking and found more and more messages
everywhere in the studio but you can't
see them with your eyes my eyes my
special ice this bores gonna knock this
on the floor - oh no where I followed
them for a long time just leads me in
circles oh I don't think I meant to
leave this place Henry oh but maybe you
are maybe Alice please let me out of
here
maybe Tom thinks you're dangerous that's
probably what do you think I I think
you're the hope I've been waiting for Oh
go to sweet oh wait wait no no no no I
saw a message that you would leave me
for dead don't sashay away from me oh
all right then
at least I got a magic looking glass is
gonna help me in some way shape or form
or not Tom you dumb Tom you dumbass
before you find this boy so stupid
you're not Boris hello I'm here okay
alright hey haha okay again with the
threatening flapping of the axe I don't
like that Tom what are having a Boris I
guess Boris got turned into a horrible
muscled monstrosity
leave him come on what's going on yeah
Tom you big dumb dumb ass use your axe
you fool look uh me me know how to do Oh
what no way no pay on wait um Tom you
have an axe
it's would you axe okay locate the gent
bye
if I could have gotten out here this
whole time there's always hope
take the spoon Oh God oh don't go
through the door escape trust her it's
inside the vault whoa whoa you draw
beautifully thank you thank you who's
talking take the spoon this is here the
whole time you mean I didn't have to
[ __ ] in a bucket oh come on this is here
oh look inside you'll need this okay let
me just stick my hand bleep and unless
you're talking about the hole oh I was
ready to go elbow deep in the [ __ ] hole
that is this toilet oh nice nice all
right
well you see how Boris or Tom could have
just easily flunked fees away Tommy
piece of crap
Tom you piece of poop Tom you and it's I
guess that's true she will leave me for
dead but she didn't want to it wasn't
malicious I guess it's fine Oh leave
this just sweet here hello fishy Wang
Wang doodle whomping are these fish
drawn to ma'am is everything drowning
here is anything actually alive
is anything actually real no ooh scary
oh hi oh we get grabbed womp womp hey
now no need for that you sack of ink I
don't need that I'm trying to explore
here I'm trying to see some secrets that
was a secret follow me okay that's not
much of a secret okay
I hear voices whispering at me from the
darkness I'm not sure if that's a good
thing
probably oh you don't need to do none of
that to me starting off with a weird
wampie combat but I guess that's okay I
mean over time in this game yeah over
time in this game I think it became less
and less about being a psychological
horror game I'm more of like the
interesting like universe that it
encompassed and once it started
embracing that I mean the last one the
last chapter had some scary moments and
I really appreciated that but I think
like overall it's because this game is
actually a really there's something in
the river a really interesting universe
and it's something that you want to
explore it can be a mixture of both and
I've got a bad feeling about this
oh well goodbye I'm sure that wasn't
supposed to happen that my boat
that a boat can I get on the boat danger
keep out okay here I go then hippity
hoppity hoppity hoppity yeah but I know
what I am maybe I should go up this way
yep but I don't know but I do do yeah
but op2 do how do I get it in you
[Music]
oh I didn't know I had to do it twice
what kind of why was it was the point of
that just to make me look stupid well
you succeeded I find now I'm here
alright follow the Inc River I don't
know I don't know why there needs to be
an Inc River I think a river of ink is a
little much I think that we could get by
without it a river of ink but alas I
don't make the decisions here I just try
my best to not screw up
I've got a bad feeling about this
Oh
this looks like oh I don't want to know
what's stuck in the paddle wheel oh
that's a big boys oh my god oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna get get out get out get out get
out I didn't know I was that close to
doom oh I gotta go through the inky
butthole again God why just in the realm
of thoughts not th OTS though uh hi
okay back into the butthole River
alright well everyone ignored the fact
that I screwed up there I am an idiot so
what's to be surprised here okay what is
the big-ass hand in the river is that
Boris because I got a funny feeling
everything comes down to Boris being a
horribly horribly horribly mangled in
two horrible horrible shapes and
everything is horrible in this game the
gameplay has gotten better I'll give it
that
I mean also I gotta remember I need to
be a little bit forgiving about the game
because at its core it's an indie game
made by a very small team maybe even the
original was made just by one person or
a small team of people and it's expanded
into something that's really caught on
and that's because the idea at its core
is in fact good the idea behind it is
captivating it's something that you
can't look away from okay I'm not gonna
okay no no no no no no no no no no we're
going for it I ain't gonna wait around
for no giant hand to come claw me
alright but it's good I don't want to
know I don't want to look behind me I
don't want to know I'm gonna assume that
it was something nice like a rainbow or
babies to shoot now
ever I don't know why that would be nice
but I just imagine that and now I'm
scared no thank you no thank you no
thank you no thank you no thing go
please I don't know I the flashing light
is necessary
hmm also there's something very
childlike about the whole disney-like
aspect of it I mean it's it's horrifying
when you really think about but it is
that kind of like childlike sense of
terror and not really like the body
horror that you would normally be used
to and yet we are in a river filled with
Pope come on try not to die to a giant
hand that's gonna claw the [ __ ] out of
me but it's it's fascinating it's
honestly truly fascinating from start to
finish it is fascinating and I like that
I like that a lot
Oh God how many times is gonna get
gunked-up I would have thought that this
stuff was supposed to be for designed
for this no no don't get a glimpse of
that that's no good that's no good at
all I like the tuba guy farting in my
ear back there it's real nice helps me
keep time regular intervals okay again
how much farther I gotta go with this
thing can't be much farther how long
would it need me to go through here
there's Boris I don't know why Baro
[Music]
um I okay we're just gonna ignore the
fact that there's an Inc person right
there and we're gonna walk into this
Futurama sewer esque
area where I'm assuming Inc people live
okay goodbye guess I'm not going back
that way
sorry everybody in this shantytown that
I just ruined the transportation system
of this bill me for that later I guess
it's time to believe he will set us free
the Creator lied to us
you bring death well I suppose maybe you
might be right hello anybody there okay
no all right well nobody wants to come
out and talk to me that's fine once
people now fallen into despair not
monsters are these the former employees
oh okay all right what do you want it
what oh okay all right
good god you have an axe I have a bumper
how is this fair and why is my blood Inc
I might like one of you okay well and
back in the butthole again who was I
supposed to run away I didn't have
anyone run man all right time for round
two yeah CH I'm gonna smack the [ __ ] out
of you I'm gonna smack your ink all over
the place
I don't like your face I don't like your
foot going to a party well
oh I can block Eifert no I can't lock
tanah block how did I beat how do I beat
anything before in this game am I just
dumb here I mean don't answer that cuz
obviously the answer is no I'm smart but
[Laughter]
it seems a little uh seems a little
difficult maybe I should just run he's
real tough okay can I go the way he came
in
oh I can oh but to what end
oh but to what end all but to what end
how about this
no okay Oh were you shy because you're
ugly you're attacking other people
because you all go oh come on now you
ain't that ugly okay well then
[Music]
hi wow thank you that was close
yeah you're lucky we were in the
neighborhood yeah I think oh okay
was that him I don't think so
The Searchers and the lost ones built
this place
Sammy must have been keeping them at bay
now that he's gone looks like we're in
for a fight huh
who are we fightin why are we fighting
anybody why do we need to fight I like
the ax thanks for the ax that's nice hey
do I need to do anything here can you do
all the work with these Amina hey yeah
oh god I'm losing again look at this
well what a surprise I'm bad at the
combat in this game who would have
thought are you stupid piles of poopy oh
this was a peaceful town
well the fisherman that I walked in and
everybody hates me oh god oh god oh god
you not can you not you guys help yeah
I've never seen this many either whoa
whoa whoa big guy big guy be good no no
no no no have I been gradually but
grudgingly one Tom's respect as well
okay we get him oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah ow ow I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die no not today now God in the butthole
Ian
did anyone play test this game I can't
be the only one that's this bad at this
I cannot be the only one that dis bad at
this cuz you can't run can't do nothing
it's just fine it's whatever you know
it's fine look at this look at this from
the far because you can't sprint when
you have this okay well I guess I need
to help out here probably you guys don't
seem capable anything Oh Oh pumpkins no
helmets I'm getting stutters my [ __ ]
god this can't be an intended part of
this I'm sorry listen you guys have to
forgive me I'm trying my best here it's
not that I'm bad is that the balance is
marginally off the malliband the male
balance it's just a little bit off this
is a little bit off and I keep getting
surrounded
they keep sneaking up behind me ha ha no
ha ha ha ha ha ha there's no defense
mechanism
ok or or I won't hit you whatever come
on oh if you meant it's so it's so
floaty it's so impossible to judge where
your axe is actually gonna hit the one
thing I said about this game from the
very beginning is that why did it need
why didn't need integrated combat
mechanics but ok here we go got a melee
why can't they give me a name gun draw
me up a gun or an artist can I deal with
this my own way which is gun
oh my god there's so many of them how
long is this gonna go on for and how
many times am I gonna return to the
butthole realm
here's another one there's no way
anybody can get through this on the
first try there's no way anybody can I'm
it's just pissing me off because they're
making me look bad but I bet anybody
that's playing this part he's going
through the whole same endeavor that I'm
going through trying their best but
getting banished back to the butthole
realm not today not again here we go
again I guess we're gonna go again
more more more more more why not more
dairy okay you weren't done yet
okay fine anymore is that it can we be
done are we done now next probably best
if we stay together from now on yeah I
would agree thank you you can leave the
way why would I know the way dude this
used to be an animation studio I don't
even know what's going on here you would
deserve a Swonk on the knows when I'm
gonna forgive you about that one we're
gonna go this way
hmm I don't know why I'm suddenly slower
than I used to be are we gonna be
separated
is this how we get separated yeah Oh
best if we stick together huh whoo okay
but no all right no we're not gonna
stick together that's just a load of
crap that was a load of crap from the
get-go all right but now we're separated
so please stay in the spooky part of it
oh god a pooping chamber huh oh my god
I've been waiting for one of these for a
long time oh sweet
Anke relief I didn't even have a toilet
in that jail cell the holding it this
whole time
Tara what have we got the goose yeah
hello ah okay
Oh huh drain the passage find the
missing pipes oh all right well I'll do
that and another scavenger hunt the
biggest part of this game's game
mechanics
[Music]
okay Thomas Connor I could barely hear
you over the sound of the music Oh Oh
Boris Boris
say you body I think I found an easter
egg a cute adorable Widow east to wake
anyone up there
no oh now the music's done oh now the
music's done when I didn't need the
music to be done now now the music's
done okay whatever fine sure okay so you
can I set this here pipe I need one of
these Bendis but I need some ink to make
into it oh I did have a voice before
what am I talking about I thought I
didn't have a voice before but then
again I'm an idiot of course we had a
voice before I don't remember anything
okay administration is opening up for
some reason the game got a lot more
floaty as soon as I open that okay guys
weird thing I hit that button and then
the mouse sensitivity went way high why
would the mouse sensitivity go higher
when I why why would why would that why
would that do that the I'm dead serious
the mouse sensitivity shot up as soon as
I open that that is beyond bizarre okay
vault
not these guys again oh oh uh well I
guess I should I wasn't sure what I was
hearing there so I didn't even know that
there was a credible threat but okay
better stay out of sight then which way
you coming buddy yeah it's what I
thought you stupid idiot you dumb doof I
don't know who put you together but that
was just as dumb as you yeah you stupid
fool you're gonna give me okay Joey drew
whatever you say Joey true we all love
you Joey drew from the tip of your head
to the tip of your show we love Joey
drew okay you ain't see nothing huh
stupid bobblehead looking mother humper
over here the creator lied to us yeah
well what else is new okay I think this
is just a fancy way around so that I
don't get snuck in on them okay that's a
hidey-hole that's good to know is it
just me or is the mouse sensitivity
creeping back up again which would be
the weirdest thing okay nothing here I
don't exactly know what I'm looking for
I'm assuming I'm looking for material
with which to eventually build the
pieces that I need but I don't know
exactly where they're going to be
I guess I just keep wandering and stop
worrying about the little things hmm
nice wall piece okay so this entire
office is also built out of ink but I
mean that much is obvious at this point
I don't think I can even be surprised at
a more of what will and will not be made
out of ink because it all is the answer
is everything
[Music]
yeah camel wait for that to go by I'm
gonna go through here and then behind it
because that's the only way I haven't
come on oh you stupid idiot you dumb
fool don't even know when I'm sneaks not
but okay that was not expected okay oh
you're gonna be right here aren't you oh
you dumb fool oh you incompetent goof
okay well I'll just run by you then I
guess you're not very fast all right oh
you're kind of fast okay whatever I'm
gonna keep going
and if I die I die it looks like I'm
about to die we're going here close the
door they'll never they know the guys I
think they know hang on I'm gonna hide
in the poop hole where'd he go welp
wingus dingus let's get out of here
we got no clue one way or another all
right
aha okay well two plus two equals you
stuffed your employees into ink monsters
and gave them Bob [ __ ] again with
your [ __ ] good lord what's wrong
with you you stupid piece of poop is it
cuz I called you dumb and ugly I'll take
back both of them and I call you
incredibly unintelligent and not good
face how's that get better you like that
better whatever I guess I'll try to
sneak alright can I take this I need a
pipe okay
I skipped by a few offices but I'll come
by on the way back to try to get him
anything in the trash can
no oh I just walk right on by stupid man
there's a lot of them for some reason
it's like they're on my scent and they
know where I am and they kind of want to
get a piece of me well good god how am I
supposed to be able to get to where I
need to go if you guys are just gonna be
a bunch of dudes she's about this I'm
never gonna be able to make any progress
you stupid piece of poop or I'm going in
that room you do not turn around okay
good ah [ __ ] nothing in here alright I'm
gonna go in that room you guys don't
turn around I don't the blinking light
is all about but blinking lines usually
round does it go right well nothing here
Oh where'd he go okay
and this place big this is a circle I
think it's a circle I think this is just
a circle yeah it's just a circle there
we go okay office of Joey drew that's
the first time that I've seen his office
hello okay but that's good
cuz that sounds like where I need to be
slurp that down feels good oh now we're
talking
don't do it Susie Susie don't do it Oh
Susie don't do it no it's a trap Susie
Joey drew he might be a little bit crazy
Joe ypres might not know what he's
talking about just go that way and keep
God yes right he's stupid
watch your step can I take this I got
some ink I don't know if this isn't
nothing
but I've got some I've got some stinky
ink okay good
maybe I can get out oh this is where
that would have looped - okay that's
good to know
okay maybe I can get eyes on another on
the way back but it looks like I might
be cut off here okay let's just see okay
there's an opening oh they might spot me
ah they didn't spot me
they did not spot me okay so where was
the Machine it was right here so if I
pop this bad boy in crank out one of
these I think I need a curvy one I think
I need one more there was another path
that I could have gone what
oh okay
I guess everything is fine oh god how
many do I need okay well I guess I just
gotta go back
maybe I can get more from the same place
over and over again
know what I gotta do I guess that's what
I gotta do so here I go oh I didn't get
this one did I get this one I think so
uh Wally why did you record your crime
for everybody to hear doesn't that seem
a little bit incriminating to you know
anything that might be okay oh oh we can
I get another I can't okay now hey
not in the butthole zone again oh god
someone please reenact this with the guy
from Twilight Zone just you have now
entered the battle zone this is a place
where reality doesn't make it oh wait a
minute
I may have found myself a shortcut I may
find myself a good old-fashioned shorty
curry I may have found myself a shorty
good I think I did I may have found
myself okay there we go
kachunk all right one more I may have
found myself Oh shorty good all right
well you don't care about nothing do you
how did everybody else lock on target to
me so quickly but you guys are just
bumbling idiots the can't even be
focused on one thing at a time almost
makes me feel foolish for dying to you
in the first place all right I call this
one the butthole shortcut cuz watch this
oh not your head
oh not your big ugly head and then you
just walk into the butthole zone and you
just kind of like stick your hand out
and you scrape some of the butthole ink
on the way out and then next thing you
know you've got a bunch butthole in your
hand
and maybe you got a stew going instead
of a suit it's a horrible inky butthole
instead of an inky butthole it's system
nightmare there you're gonna need years
of therapy to
if I even get out of here in the first
place I don't think therapy's gonna even
remotely change anything about this
because I'm pretty sure my interiors are
all inked at this point anyway here we
go
don't know why that was set up to be
like that but okay of course you know
the decontamination zone into the vault
with ink right
[Music]
okay I just had to do that you guys know
what it's like I had to I had no choice
okay so something broke in or out of
this vault that's the first obvious
thing the why why would there be giant
pipes of ink flowing into the wall this
seems like it seems like bad security
right here I've got a funny feeling
about this hi you should drop look I
know where we have to go but it's not
gonna be pleasant the ink diamond has
something that we need I'm going after
him you want to go to his lair are you
crazy yeah okay
I've tied a bunch it's convenient
probably through that door very
convenient I'll need three gears a
crowbar oh yeah hell yeah no more
hunting for gears Tom you're all right
in my book you get a little rub on your
noggin
you little pet Tom you are just a
dreamboat okay alright also side note
don't mess with Tom because Tom punch
your chest into your ass wait a minute
wait a minute
wait there's my old desk now I've wasted
so much time in this chair wait a minute
are we back like towards the beginning
of the game why why should we not hey
hey hey hey hey hey oh God
that saw that don't look so good that
thing don't look good at all oh that's
some kind of gangly oh you got like some
problem with your spine there alright
see ya I'm supposed to be real quiet so
I have a nice day goodbye death
yep confirmed okay death has been
confirmed okay good alright is this the
ink machine Tom punch the oceans we
can't we're not like you Henry if we go
in there Wow a drop of water in the
ocean is where we're seen again oh I
guess it's all up to me I can't see you
you're all blur do we even know what I'm
doing here I don't even know why this is
all happening to me you
here for a reason Henry there's always a
reason not always not always reason
understand it good you got a hello Tom
you got an arm alright well I guess I'm
going alone again
you guys are abandoning me and it's not
fun it's not cool in any way shape or
form so here I go
Wally Beauty daughter dog loser well did
it throw me your ax clunk all right
thank you
I miss Boris I'm guessing this must be
the official English I mean I know in
Chapter one there was the ink machine in
there that was originally pumping out
the ink but I'm guessing this might
actually be the ink machine well you
guys look like a whole bunch of fun why
are you looking away you shy oh and hey
Tom and/or Boris how are you doing oh
[Applause]
what a lovely lovely lovely place or a
throne is this a throne I'm gonna guess
it's a throne a quite bondage II throne
but nonetheless
oh hi hello are you doing a grumbly it
was you got a grumbly in your - oh
that's a big hand whew that's a strong
grabber yeah the hooks your strangling
heads Oh who's a big boy
Oh who's a big boy who's a big boy
I love thumbnail moments ow
okay thank you
oh well uh Oh what where am i oh oh well
um to who this I am outmatched in every
way shape or form I'll just take a
breather in the butthole dimension cuz I
have no idea what you want from me hey I
think I was supposed to dodge if I had
to guess I think this the main point
here is that I'm supposed to dodge whoa
well he's just having a good time
he's just a scampering okay I think
there might be a pattern to his running
maybe yeah there's a pattern okay so he
doesn't come this way he was how he's
gonna go left to right across in front
of me no yep yes then he goes that way
okay there's a switch
I like flipping switches I don't know
what they do but I got it wait a minute
as soon as he goes
gonna go zooming back this way and he's
gonna come right through there yeah okay
we got the pattern a little bit down so
I just got to stay out of trouble for as
long as I can
oh [ __ ] yeah well I mean he's just he's
having a good old time
what is this dude I have no idea
oh it opened the door pass handy all
right where does this door go oh I need
to find I see okay this is gonna be the
door out I just got to find all of the
switches it's just too terribly bad cuz
this is a matter of avoiding uh avoiding
his stampede that's not so bad
okay there's another one
okay so where would another be is
another
okay I got to imagine that they're all
opening the same doors it's funny
because he's he's really not that bad
he's just a cuddly guy that likes to run
he's just scampering I just interrupted
his exercise hour that's all really is
okay I'm gonna take a gander he's gonna
come barreling oh no it's open okay well
I guess that was all of them
easy enough see you buddy
she on the other side have a good day
catch you on the next life I guess all
right oh I got troll oh no I didn't Oh
who's laughing now Wow
and I don't know always laughing I
haven't seen any more secrets from this
thing but this looks like a final arena
type whatever all right let's do it
I mean I was never laughing in the first
place I'm not really the type to laugh
in the face of danger I'm more detective
just buckle over and just sob
uncontrollably in the face of danger ah
here we go
found it the one inconspicuous oh hey
how's it going there now you don't hey
you want to play okay that's a little oh
all right I didn't do that oh excuse me
there's a box in my right
hey I didn't know that that's what I was
supposed to do but apparently it was so
I'm doing good
hey come on hey stupid you big dumb goof
you missed you're supposed to hit this
thing is stupid my headache hit what you
gonna do okay wait this is a problem
okay you already broke that one you
didn't need to break it again you big
dog stupid what
what happened Oh what what what what
happened why did everything go black
that was weird
okay I'm not gonna really read into it
too much okay back on the third
hey the chair is mine if this chair
shares mine oh that was all I needed to
do why didn't you oh hey uh hello oh
yeah yeah movie time come on let's watch
a movie movie time don't worry about
them
Oh No for end
[Music]
[Applause]
and then he's gone Oh
anybody in the pooper Oh scary very
scary Oh big Boris oh wow it's all the
games okay well that's kind of cool all
right so soon I didn't expect you for
another hour yet now you're just trying
to impress me but I know I know you have
questions you always do the only
important question is this who are we
Henry I thought I knew who I was but the
success starved me nothing left but
lines on the page and the end we
followed two different roads of our own
making you a lovely family me a crooked
Empire and my road burned I let our
creations become my life the truth is
you were always so good at pushing
though friend pushing me to do the right
thing you should have pushed a little
harder
Henry come visit the old workshop
there's something I need to show you
all right Joey I'm here let's see if we
can find what you wanted me to see wait
hang on hold up
take a second
hold it hey wait up hold on so this
whole place was in this old guy's back
yard okay I'm cool that's fine all right
don't get it that's okay I don't know
why everything is so wrong
Boris went a little wrong but that's all
right Joe J Thomas all right I don't
understand anything that happened here
but there is one more chance and I will
see it soon there's one more thing in
the end of this game to be seen even if
I'm very confused even if I'm incredibly
incredibly confused at this entire
operation within this guy's back room
somehow machine congratulations on your
success your best pal Harry Stein
[Music]
I am very confused and I don't
understand anything
anything at all something don't add up
here I don't know what is happening in
this game I'm really confused old
[Music]
cuz I really am I'm really honestly
truly trying to piece it together
exactly what the story cuz obviously
that that last sequence that last
sentence that tell me another one uncle
Joey like all of this I think the point
it's trying to make is that all this is
just ideas come to life
in ink like that's old thing these
stories these shows this movie this
whole universe they're all part of the
worries and in a way them coming to life
is no different than them coming to life
in an animation in a in a video or in an
animation in anything like that but at
the same time it's a little bit
confusing and I'm wondering what the
connection is between everything because
what it like what is the point that
they're trying to make what is the what
is the end result out of this right are
you just trying to keep it open-ended so
open-ended it'd be like anything's
possible with the power of imagination
were you trying to say that like this is
the this is the end result of a man so
obsessed with his creations that he
actually did bring them to life in a
perverted quest for building his own
Empire and it burned around him again
like that whole intro sequence of like
go check out the old workshop and then
going there you have unlocked the seeing
tool in all previous chapters well I'm
not gonna go through the whole game with
the seeing tool even though that would
be cool but I'm not gonna do that but I
am gonna go to the archives
so we go here and we go they did also
they remade the first chapter I will say
that but I'm gonna go to the archives
here because I want to know what is the
dealio with this
welcome to the archives Benny in the egg
machine began when the developer
cartoonists known as the meetly
experimented with bringing a sketch 2d
style into a 3d world after turning the
idea into a horror game chapter one of
the game was created in a little under a
week with programmer friend Mike mood
and released on February 10th in 2017
much their surprise has struck a chord
with global indie gamers almost
overnight the meet Lee and Mike mood
decided to drop all of the projects to
work on Benny and tell the most unique
ink story the entire game was completed
a chapter at a time in a year and a half
by a small but dedicated group of indie
developers although the concept and
story remained as originally intended
the game changed over development as
characters and models were refined from
their early thrown-together versions
this archive is a sneak peek behind the
scenes at that process interesting I'm
gonna do this more of a narrated guiding
style ooh okay let's start from left to
right we will love the art I love the
whole art of this place oh my goodness
gracious oh oh oh my oh my oh my oh my
concept bendy this is the first version
of bendy ever modeled in the earliest
concepts bendy was much smaller and
cuter with a face that split open to
reveal a terrifying mouth I love that I
love that entirely I love that
completely that is terrifying they
should have used that in some way shape
or form they should have used that
because that is horrifying alpha bendy
okay I remember this one this is the
original game use design of ink bendy
from the earliest version of chapter 1
it is jokingly referred to as herb poop
with a smile among the development team
yeah I could kind of see that but it
does have a very like interesting
silhouette it looks very muscular
without actually being overly bulky and
that's kind of a weird threatening
stance to it I actually don't like the
design of the final boss very much it's
just very um I don't know it's
nonsensical in a way and it just didn't
seem very threatening whereas the other
one was slight and I don't know just
seemed like it was a morphus and
could be anything whereas au is just a
big muscle monster which is something
that I don't really like in horror
things beta bendy this was inked Bendis
form until the release of chapter 4 at
that time the game received a major
visual upgrade and the key title
character got a new model as well okay
pretty cool ink bendy ink bendy as we
know him today although similar to beta
bendy this upgraded version was
remodelled enhanced with a higher
polygon count and given new ink effects
okay now this I like this I really like
cuz it's got this weird bony skeletal
structure and the face is obviously
leering and more peeking out from
underneath ink but at the same time I
got I gotta go with this one I really do
I really like that one or this one as
opposed to this one wins one is nice
with a higher poly count and everything
but there's something about this one
that's just like unnaturally disturbing
in its silhouette whereas this one just
seems like I'm a monster it looks like
one of the imps from doom whereas this
one just seems like I'm trying to be hue
like hello fellow human I am bendy you
know in the way yeah beasts bendy inch
Bendis horrific final form in Chapter
five pulled away from the cartoon facade
and revealed the demon within yeah I
kind of see what you were going for and
like in static it's kind of cool but at
the same time I don't know it just feels
like it detracts from the actual horror
element of it I feel like when a lot of
things go overly muscular and and too
big you know with a lot of like sharp
teeth and shark style like I I get that
it's it the idea is scary but the
execution often falls flat because I'm a
funny little liquor but that's not the
point like it just it's less horrific
and more just like I'm a brute I'm a big
dumb brute whereas this one and is
inherently more interesting I think
that's his personally though beta
searcher early in development with just
a few weeks to create chapter 2 the beta
searchers were designed in record time
before being fully retooled later on
they were the first fighting enemies
encountered in the game hate you hey you
very much I didn't even notice the mouth
there that's interesting that's a final
searcher okay hate you also I love these
guys though
even though they're dumb and they're a I
wasn't too good I liked
far more robust in appearance they were
smoother with better ink effects and a
more human appearance I'll take your
word for that one beta Sammy with his
first appearance in Chapter two fan
favorite Sammy Lawrence became a
terrifyingly entertaining character when
his slim build was deemed not
threatening enough he was redesigned and
given a better skeletal rig for more
advanced emanation ah again I disagree
III don't think final Sammy Sammy
Lawrence's final form came complete with
a bulked up stature and more powerful
limbs the mad songwriter may finally get
notice now at least by fans see I
disagree I don't think that adding
muscles or bulking them up in any way is
more interesting to them I think that
the the overalls are modelled better and
fit his form a little better but I don't
think bulking him up inherently makes
him more threatening I think it just
makes him seem more like a more like a
1920s like rail worker or something like
that someone working in the iron like
the iron departments the thing is if
he's a musician he doesn't look like a
musician I feel like there's nothing
even to give him any sort of personality
to this I I don't think muscles is the
right way to go to give impersonality
it's an inherently interesting thing
where this guy goes mad and like takes
on the face of bendy but at the same
time I feel like there could be a
different direction not that I have
anything off the top of my head but you
know I'm kind of thought of the original
BioShock you remember like the the
photographer that like actually like
cast the corpses of the people like in
different ways the weird elegance that
he had I feel like the l-like if this is
the sound designer and all the music
form of it like it's like the musicians
not gonna be bulked up like a musician's
gonna be fancy a musician's gonna try to
retain the fanciness in some way shape
or form but then that again that's just
my opinion I don't even know about you
there's no message about you
hello so which one of these was the
actual human that was turned into the
monster I think this one must have been
the human that was turned into the
monster and this one's actually just the
character brought to life you know what
I mean
there's Tom ah betta Boris Papa papa
papa
oh hi papa yeah papa was the original
name of the character that eventually
became Boris the wolf this early version
was released with chapter 1 he was
quickly refined into the Boris we know
today with the release of chapter 2 who
I loved donahoo tom is screw Tom Boris
the wolf a friend to the end was
designed using various references for
cartoons of the 1920s a blend of West
Coast and East Coast animation styles
the silent and supportive wolf won over
the hearts of many although at times he
was a headache for the development team
due to be as AI taking a mind of its own
during production yeah but that's what
made him cute Oh big Boris brute Boris
now this is now this is a good example
of brute like meeting a horror style
taking something that you once loved and
turning it into a brute I think that
kind of works better than taking
something you hate and turning it into a
brute like else
angels monstrosity brute Boris was one
of the biggest surprises of chapter 4
his design was roughly based on the
Frankenstein monster but with a more
unfinished appearance Alice took parts
from within him and substituted thing
that his body is rapidly rejected yeah I
can kind of see that see a lot of the
elements of what what you take from
before is is made in a horrified way see
the other one it's not enhanced by its
bulk the bulkiness of it doesn't enhance
anymore of it because it doesn't make it
twist it in any way it just bulks it out
this one takes something that was
adorable and cute and retains enough of
the features of its original cuteness so
that you can see the perversion that
happened to it and I think that's a good
thing about it the head is still exactly
the same shape you can kind of get the
sense of the overalls and now they're
stretching and ripping at the seams like
this bone jutting out of this leg here
that's kind of cool and the weird the
weird way like the juxtaposition of the
hands and stuff and the sense of it
kinda is is good in a way because you
you can see what you've lost and I think
that's really neat about it um lastly
here we have the ink machine before a
major visual upgrade this version of the
ink machine was the one the game used in
the game much of the machine's iconic
fan loved design was translated into the
final version yeah there's the ink
machine alright oh this guy I love that
now that was a cool boss that was a
really cool boss I think a little like
the gameplay could have used some
tweaking but it was still really cool oh
here we go
the butcher game the piper striker and
Fischer made up the dreaded butcher game
interestingly the in corrupted versions
of the characters were designed first
and then were reverse engineered back
into their more friendly family friendly
cartoon forms there's nothing not
family-friendly about this what's not
family-friendly about these lovely
lovely things anyway all criticisms that
I have are not like not to be taken like
in any way sort of like with expert
opinion these are just my opinions those
are just what I would do if I had the
ability to do it but I don't have the
ability to do it because I am not
necessarily an artist I am just a player
of games I've never made one myself but
that is just my idea behind it but this
has been bendy and the egg machine I
liked it I really do I have a lot of
problems with the gameplay but I've
never ever had a problem with this story
with the idea behind it the world the
environment I think it's very original I
think it's really cool to see I think it
brings a lot to the table and I think
there's a lot to be learned from the
experience and I can't wait to see what
they make next
whatever this company does they've hit
it really big with a lot of success ooh
that's scary no if it actually had eyes
like that it would have been a lot
scarier oh my god that's terrifying oh I
hate that
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this adventure into bendy and the egg
machine and let me know what you thought
down in the comments below if you want
to play this for yourself and see the
secrets of the mirror throughout the
beginning of the game you can play the
game I'll put a link in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching
always remember to support the indie
developers who make these great games
that we can all love and enjoy and thank
you all so much again and as always I
will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]